ist das vielleicht das neue atem gas für
astronauten astronauten ein us
forschungsteam hat jetzt einen bislang
unbekannten reaktionsweg entdeckt bei
dem kohlendioxid auf sehr einfache weise
in sauerstoff umgewandelt wird anders
als bei den bisher bekannten reaktionen
ist dafür weder besonders viel energie
noch ein zusätzlicher reaktionspartner
notwendig klicks am science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen es ist wirklich verflixt
anders als in der erdatmosphäre kommt
sauerstoff o2 weder in den gas hüllen
unserer nachbarn planeten noch sonst wo
im sonnensystem in ausreichenden oder
gar großen mengen vor astronautinnen und
astronaut müssen sich bei künftigen
langzeitmissionen wie beispielsweise auf
den mars ihren sauerstoff zum atmen also
selbst herstellen dafür kommen
unterschiedliche ausgangsmaterialien
infrage wie zum beispiel wasser sie die
karte oder auch kohlendioxid doch um
letzterem seine beiden sauerstoff atome
wegzunehmen ist ein riesiger
energieeinsatz und ein weiterer
zusätzlicher reaktionspartner nötig so
war es zumindest bisher doch ein us
forschungsteam hat jetzt entdeckt das
kohlendioxid auch oft deutlich
einfachere art und weise zu sauerstoff
zerfallen kann eine entdeckung der
raumsonde rosetta brachte die fachleute
auf die idee zu dieser forschung die
europäische raumsonde hatte nämlich in
der gashülle des kometen tschurjumow
gerasimenko sauerstoff nachgewiesen eine
wirklich erstaunliche entdeckung denn
welche reaktionen laufen in solch einer
extremen umwelt ab so dass sauerstoff
frei wild der direkte zerfall von co2 in
o2 und ein kohlenstoffatom erschien den
experten und expertinnen also zunächst
als äußerst ungewöhnlich begründet liegt
dies in der struktur des co2 moleküls
tassen linear ist also in der einfach
der länge nach und somit extrem verbogen
werden muss damit sich die beiden
sauerstoff atome die an den beiden enden
liegen kontaktieren schnell war klar
eine solche umlagerung der einzelne
atome im co2 moleküle würde einen
enormen energie einsatz erfordern dazu
constantinos yapis der an der studie
beteiligt war
wir dachten deshalb das ist unmöglich
ist die beiden sauerstoff atome eines
co2 moleküls auf diese weise zu
verbinden
man muss schließlich etwas ziemlich
drastisches mit diesem molekül
veranstalten gesagt getan und so schoss
das forschungsteam einen strom aus co2
moleküle auf eine goldfolie das alles
passiert dem vakuum und durch den
einsatz von reaktionsträge gold gold
reagiert nur schlecht mit anderen
substanzen konnten die fachleute
ausschließen dass dieses keineswegs
selbst als reaktionspartner agieren kann
oder sogar selbst sauerstoff freigesetzt
und das ergebnis war wirklich
verblüffend denn ein kleiner teil der
co2 moleküle wandelte sich tatsächlich
in sauerstoff um genau genommen wurde
allein durch die kollision des co2
stroms mit dem gold ein bis zwei prozent
sauerstoff produziert und das ganz ohne
katalysator oder zusätzlichen
reaktionspartner eine überraschung sogar
für die fachleute selbst weniger
überraschend dagegen dass der größte
teil an co2 in seine einzelne atome
zerfiel oder aber zu atomarem sauerstoff
also ozon und kohlenmonoxid die genaue
chemische reaktionen die nach dem
auftrag abläuft beschreibt die studie
folgendermaßen als erstes kollidiert das
führende sauerstoffatom mit einem gold
atom des untergrunds dann folgt der
aufprall des coo molekül rest so
entsteht im großteil der fälle
kohlenmonoxid das führende
sauerstoffatom durch die harte kollision
abgesprengt wird doch bei etwa fünf
prozent der kollision passiert etwas
anderes durch den aufprall verformt sich
das co2 moleküle bleibt aber intakt
beide sauerstoff atome kommen sich näher
und binden sich quasi aneinander
das forschungsteam fast seine ergebnisse
so zusammen im verlauf dieser intra
molekularen reorganisation bekommt das
co2 eine dreieckige konfiguration mit
nahezu gleichen bindungs längen zwischen
den atomen das molekül disloziert zu
einem freien kohlenstoffatom und einem
co2 moleküle durch die bindung der
beiden sauerstoff atome wird das
kohlenstoff atomen freigegeben ein
wirklich toller erfolg denn diese
bislang unbekannte reaktion ist unter
relativ simplen umständen möglich
zusammengefasst müssen die gasmoleküle
lediglich beschleunigt werden und auf
ein hindernis bleiben dazu konstantinos
jobs mit genügend tempo könnte man sogar
eine steine in etwas co2 werfen und man
würde das gleiche erzählt der stein
müsste nur etwa so schnell sein wie ein
komet oder asteroid im all diese
reaktion könnte daher für
astrophysikalischen umgebungen wie
kometen mond und planeten mit co2
atmosphären relevant sein
und damit schließt sich der kreis zu
ursprungs entdeckung der rosetta sondern
auch der molekulare sauerstoff in der
gashülle des kometen tschurjumow
gerasimenko könnte so entstanden sein
das forschungsteam jedenfalls ist sich
sicher dass dieser neu entdeckte
reaktionsweg auch in der raumfahrt von
großer bedeutung sein könnte
beispielsweise könnten maß
astronautinnen und astronauten aus der
co2 atmosphäre des roten planeten atem
gas herstellen doch klar ist auch dass
die ausbeute an sauerstoff dafür noch
nicht groß genug ist dazu heißt es in
der studie
ist dies schon ein gerät mit dem wir das
sauerstoff probleme auf dem mars lösen
können nein aber es ist eine methode wie
etwa sehr schwieriges kann um den
aktuellen reaktionsweg effektiver zu
gestalten
soll er jetzt mit weiteren reaktions
wegen kombiniert werden so könnte die
erzeugte sauerstoffmenge gesteigert
werden mission rosetta ist
revolutionären dafür anklicken in diesem
video erfahrt ihr mehr über diese
spektakulärer mission anschauen und
natürlich klicks um dann abonnieren
falls das noch nicht getan haben sollte
bis dann bleib dran